tenemos este número 0.07 27 y queremos
convertirlo a una fracción y bueno la
forma que más me gusta a mí para hacer
eso es ver cada uno de estos números
qué fracción representan el número que
está aquí representa a las décimas el
número que está aquí representa a las
centésimas donde una décima lo que
representa es pues una décima parte de
uno y una centésima pues significa uno
entre ciento una centésima parte del uno
y este lugar es el de las milésimas
es el de las 10 milésimas
entonces como la posición en este número
más a la derecha es el de las 10
milésimas entonces este número es
equivalente a 727 10 milésimas como este
es el lugar de las 10 milésimas entonces
estamos dividiendo entre 10.000 y listo
porque este no parece ser un número
divisible entre 2 ni tampoco entre 3 y 5
de hecho ni siquiera entre 7 y como no
es divisible entre 3 entonces
definitivamente no es divisible entre 6
ni entre 9 y pues la verdad no sabemos
pero parece ser que este es un número
primo aunque tendríamos que verificar
más cosas para ver qué es primo